well test driver Chris Castillo says he
loves the roar as much as the ride
for almost three decades BMWs been
taking the m3 only one direction fast
faster and faster still now generation
five is stepping up to the mark with
greater performance but a smaller engine
downsizing is the watchword for the new
M models and that doesn't sound quite
right technical innovation could
describe the trend as well point to the
first carbon fibre driveshaft or roof
fashioned in carbon these tricks and
others make the car 80 kilograms lighter
than its predecessor
Chris says he can choose between the
efficiency Sport and Sport Plus modes
efficient provides absolute driving
comfort and keep still use down but if
he presses the Sport Plus button high
fuel consumption is part of the fun for
Paolo nutini's xov Thompson the new
engine is a twin turbocharged straight-6
it delivers eight kilowatts more than
the previous model to top out at 317
kilowatts with maximum torque of 550
Newton metres average fuel consumption
has been cut by more than 25% to 8.8
litres per 100 kilometres and co2
emissions of 204 grams per kilometer
in photos our test driver says the m3
transforms into a pure racing machine
and Sport Plus mode acceleration is
breathtaking and the brakes clamped down
hard for agile handling Chris put some
of that down to the car
having the carbon ceramic brake option
and Germany the cost for the racing
brake extra is seven thousand three
hundred euros the powerful dynamics of
the bmw m3 sedan are unmistakable big
air intakes guarantee optimal cooling of
the a mention no matter where the car is
performing
the BP power dome hood neatly fits the
shape of the turbocharger assembly
beveled four-barrel chrome pipes at the
rear contribute to the beamers
characteristic growl
but the side contours are what proved
that form has been optimally merged with
function the curve of the roofline gives
the four-door sedan a high-performance
sporty look that makes the black carbon
roof of the vehicle appear lower than it
actually is reduces the cars weight and
lowers its center of gravity
Chris says the steering is precise and
tight he doesn't feel like he might lose
control in a curve but that the optional
switch to make the steering even tighter
doesn't seem to do much so it looks like
the m3 sedan will likely keep its called
status chris says it's a great car with
excellent performance but that the base
price of 70,000 euros makes it a bit too
expensive for him